[Musique]
holy notre vie normale monde les gens
vont travailler les gens gros c'est
comme menées avec les enfants
les enfants des écoles
où il y à des écoles dannemarie là on a
les experts ont vite tout à fait
normalement mais en même temps on fait
avec avec la guerre donc on fait ricco
l'ipo nos
soldats il est réfugié en a beaucoup
plus que 200 milles et ça arrive plus et
plus
[Musique]
mais après vous avez les villes où les
gens sont bleues qu'elles peuvent pas
quitter
pour le sommet
butch il ne pouvait pas quitter si
facilement
les jantes sont 25 les on n'a pas de
connexion n'a pas de réseau vous n'avez
pas de gaz vous n'avez pas de l'homme
savait rien du tout il ya déjà les viols
les vols dit pas mais il ya déjà les
viols qui qui sont commis et qui vont
être en forte augmentation
s'inquiète un peu bientôt
plus tôt on attend
on attend
au moins on vous avait déjà plein vous
attendez seulement vous faites avec
les gens qui sont nés ici oncle percer
ou en fait avec ça tout et tout ce qui
vous adressez aux
esprits comme ce qui trait combattants
patriotes qu'ils voulaient sauter
partout et à son envie de gagner il plus
vite possible
[Musique]